as you can see uh joining us now on the
sofa the justice secretary the deputy
prime minister dominic rapp lovely to
see you this morning and and we do have
a significant announcement
that we will get to and i promise you
we'll spend some time on that but i do i
i do need to start with the resignation
of lord
geig hand on heart
do you believe that this government
always 100 of the time operates
ethically
yes i do i think we're doing our best
for the country i think you've seen that
through the pandemic with a vaccine
rollout i think you've seen it with
getting the economy back up and running
i think you've seen the moral leadership
the prime minister's shown on ukraine do
we make mistakes look it happens we're
human we're fallible but actually in
relation to partygate which is what
you're alluding to prime minister held
up his hand he's apologized he's
overhauled number 10. i do think also
people expect us to get on with that
crucial job particularly with the cost
of living challenge affecting so many
people i can i completely agree people
definitely want you to get on with the
job but but i do need to ask why has a
second ethics advisor resigned from this
government what are lord guides stated
reasons for doing this well the stated
reasons of course he set out
overnight but were were very limited so
um he just said he thought it was the
right time to step down look let me tell
you what i know um
first of all he had been engaged with
the prime minister and number 10 this
week
and discussing staying on for six months
so
i think my understanding had been he was
committed to the role uh i think he had
a pretty rough grilling by mps this week
i think sometimes we in the media as
politicians uh maybe underestimate how
civil servants uh feel with that kind of
scrutiny and thirdly there was a
particular issue commercially sensitive
matter in the national interest which he
was asked to look at i don't know which
aspect of this i suspect there will be
in fact i know there will be an update
from number 10 later which will be great
but that will be their response to his
letter why have we not seen lord gait's
resignation letter that's pretty
unprecedented for such circumstances
such as this well he's given a statement
um and i can't tell you i'm not a
psychologist it's not a statement it's a
sentence he has written info to the
prime minister as people do generally
when they're hired by this government
and they choose to resign they set out
their reasons at least for departure he
has done so to the prime minister i
didn't i so i did i don't know that
whether there's a full letter or whether
a full letter in reply will come out
there'll be an update from number 10
later today genuinely now as always
trying to do when we i'm telling you
what i know
when will he be replaced because with
respect it does rather feel that getting
another ethics advisor might be a
priority for this government and look i
think the role role's important we'll do
it as soon as possible i think number 10
have made that clear
and you don't perhaps detect any
problems in hiring a third ethics
advisor in in as many years i mean you
hired a new cost of living czar the
other day david buttress who said the
boris has got to go he just has to you
can't survive judgment like this when
you're at the point of having to hire
people who have explicitly stated that
boris johnson should resign all is not
well in government well i'm going to put
it the other way i think the fact that
he is notwithstanding previous tweets he
may have made but willing to serve under
this government under the leadership of
the prime minister
is a positive i think it says a number
of things i'm not sure quite sure that
people will agree with you that it's a
positive i think it says something about
mr buttress but it's not just of course
lord guide that resigned uh this week
last week you had the anti-corruptions
are resigned john penrose
well look john's a an mp i think he was
clear on his christians the prime
minister i've worked with him on things
like the magnitsky sanctions i'm afraid
i just disagree i mean look we know that
there are conservative mps who have been
critical of the prime minister but he
had 59 support uh and we're getting on
with the job as i as i mentioned okay
you mentioned
two in five of your parliamentary
colleagues in the best case scenario
basically all of the back benches feel
that the prime minister does not have
the ability to lead neither the party
either the party or the country the
anti-corruptions are goes last week
making his complaints very public we
have lord gait two days ago saying that
the prime it would be reasonable to say
that the prime minister had broken the
ministerial code and then he resigns the
following day you take all of that
together and it is your position that
this does not reflect badly on the prime
minister look i think we've had a
difficult patch but getting on with the
job you haven't really asked me any
questions with respect to you
does any of that reflect on the prime
minister's integrity a little bit
look no i asked all these questions uh
monday last when we had the vote of
confidence 59 of mps back the pm we're
getting on with their job the challenge
of the cost of living we've still got an
acute issue in relation to ukraine that
can't just slip off the radar um and i'm
talking about rape course and the
crucial job we're doing fighting crime
and giving women greater confidence in
the justice system okay here's the
really simple question to use not one
but two ethics advisers and an
anti-corruption czar your position is
that does not reflect negatively on the
prime minister's integrity i mean that's
nonsense well in relation to lord guide
it's not clear to me at all uh that
what the reason is and so i mean i think
you've been asking me about that there
are clearly these issues um around the
other commercially uh sensitive matter
which he was engaged on or asked to
advise on my understanding was that
again to the best of my knowledge uh as
of earlier this week he was planning or
he was hoping to stay on for another six
months he's obviously had that grilling
in front of mps so i think
the risk is you're adding one plus one
and getting three but i understand we're
asking the question there'll be a
further update from number 10 later
would you would you if you were in
number 10 right now not republish the
statement that the letter that he wrote
to the prime minister you may have to
redact if there are if there are issues
of national security or whatever else
you can redact the letter but the fact
that you haven't put in the public
domain the resignation letter of the
second ethics adviser to depart
government looks awful well look i i i
only know what he said i don't i didn't
know and i don't know whether he's
written a letter or not what i do know
is number 10 will provide an update
later on today so you're not going to
have to wait too long i appreciate all
the gaps what i always like to do when i
come on here is tell you the best the
best of my knowledge what i know and i
always appreciate it let's dwell a
little bit closer to your brief on the
issue of rwanda the front of the daily
mail this morning yeah seems to suggest
that you would be willing or the
government is considering at some point
in the future ignoring decisions
judgments handed down by the european
court of human rights it was barely 24
hours ago yeah your colleague treason
coffee italy's coffee was sitting there
telling me that this was a law-abiding
government i mean that's nonsense if
this is true
no
you again um a slight caricature of what
is a complex legal position so first of
all we'll be introducing and publishing
our bill of rights shortly
one of the issues that's arisen is
whether strasbourg has a power of
injunction now this issue on whether
these deportation flights should be
stayed pending a further trial of all
the for the hearing of all the issues in
a few weeks time was considered by the
high court mr justice swift read the
judgments very interesting he clearly
said no there's no need for an
injunction it was then considered by the
court of appeal they backed him
wholeheartedly supreme court said no
need for there was no leave to appeal to
the supreme court i think
when three courts and i have got great
respect for judiciary in this country
have considered dismissed the issue it
is not right for strasbourg uh to
intervene in the way it did you're
limitless physical we're just we're
we're just the year let me explain why i
said high court court of appeals supreme
court where does the eca so let me so
first of all actually the european
convention if you look at it has no
power of injunction and indeed the
strasbourg court we have followed
judgments of the echrings
tonight
actually
i'm not gonna get the answers your
viewers need unless you just allow me to
briefly explain it i'll take any
question you like on this issue the
strasbourg itself has said for many
years that there's no binding power of
injunction and then later on they said
well actually we can issue such binding
judgments it is not grounded in the
convention what i would say to you is we
should abide by the convention but so
should the strasbourg court and on this
specific issue of whether strasbourg can
injunct uh
the uk our bill of rights will correct
that and i think it's the right thing to
do precisely because
we should be following the convention
but also so should the strasbourg court
are you considering stepping back from
the european convention on human rights
changing it yesterday therese coffee
appeared to suggest no lunchtime the pm
spokesman appeared to suggest yes well
look if you're asking me forever in a
day i think we need to see the no no no
our plan and i've already consulted on
it so everyone can see is a bit of
rights that reflects and remains within
the european convention but overhauls
the the framework of the human rights
act and make sure that we can fully
avail ourselves of what's called the
margin of appreciation which is what the
strasbourg court says national
jurisdictions are allowed to do in
particular in cases like this okay let's
talk uh just just just briefly one final
point in all of this and the the prime
minister has accused your former
colleagues in the legal profession as a
betting the work of criminal gangs i
just want to show you um one tweet
kailyn gallacher is a qc
she has basically
she's had to be confront she'd had to
have a conversation
with the police because of threats that
have been made to her life if you can
get it into the world yeah and
today i met a police officer about death
threats i've got for being a human
rights lawyer today i read the pm's
words criticizing lawyers representing
asylum seekers these things are not
unrelated this government is undermining
the rule of law and putting us all at
risk at the very least will you push
back on this idea that anyone who
represents an asylum seeker about to be
deported to rwanda is some form of lefty
lawyer whatever that is well look so
first of all let me choose my words very
carefully as the justice secretary i
think that i've already been very
complimentary i think about the role of
our judges i don't comment on individual
cases but as i mentioned high court
court of appeal and supreme court on
these issues uh i i believe we should
respect their rules
between the prime minister's words and
the death and the threats to our life
that she is look at any threat to any
lawyer or anyone else and politicians
get this a lot and i know journalists do
absolutely are unacceptable but the
point that pm made is this and look i
know the lawyers work heroically through
covid and with the backlog we need them
and they're crucial to getting the
backlogs down could you tell your
colleagues that then i'm running hold on
i also think i'm sorry i also think it's
fair to say
that we've got with the human rights act
elastic interpretations of human rights
an industry that has grown up which of
course wants to take advantage of those
in their interests their clients and i
think it's right to say we want to
reform some of that but but i also would
say we've got a world-leading legal
profession it's one of the great exports
we have around the world and i'm very
proud of them and there are no threats
against them that can ever be justified
they will they will be very pleased to
hear you say that let's now go to your
announcement and as i said it is it is a
significant announcement but at the same
time we should also point out for the
time being at least a pilot
well um
yes and actually we ought to pilot
things to see the evidence of course of
course let me make two points first of
all uh the backlogs because of the
pandemic uh the plight of cases
particularly for rape victims i think is
it's gotten worse it was it was bad
beforehand come on
let me answer the question actually in
the last year convictions in rape cases
have gone up by two-thirds i want to go
first further faster and really grip
this issue there's a whole range of
things we're doing what i'm announcing
today is three specialist court rooms
kitted out to deal with rape and
serosexual violence we've chosen
snaresbook in london leeds newcastle
because they've got a high volume of
rape cases and significant backlogs
we're kitting them out with the video
technology the trauma trained court
staff and the independent sexual
advisors for two reasons first of all
morally we must put our arms around
those most vulnerable uh traumatized
victims it's the right thing to do
second of all that will drive up further
the volume of convictions which i want
to at least double over the course of
this parliament and just on that point
to conclude i do have to let you go but
the reason that this is a significant
announcement is because for a number of
years now this country has been
performing incredibly poorly when it
comes to securing rape convictions
2015-16 we had 4 643
1557 um up to 2020 2020 2021
some have accused this government of
failing women you may well be putting it
right but you have to concede that for a
number of years now this government has
been getting it wrong well
of course the police are independent the
cps are independent judiciary
independent but are then have the
numbers been too low absolutely we
should be absolutely crystal clear we're
doing a whole range of things the police
and the prosecutors under operation
satiria which i look at with kit malt
house the um police minister is getting
a better collaborative approach between
them we're overhauling the disclosure
rules we've got more pre-recorded victim
evidence so the victims of rape don't
have to give their evidence in front of
the glare of the courtroom we've got
these specialist courtrooms fitted out
and can i just say again the volume of
convictions in rate cases is up by
two-thirds the
law level
very very okay but even from 2019
they're up by close to a third and the
the length of time between charge and
completion of case of cases is down by
38 days on last last year is there a
major challenge absolutely uh have the
levels of convictions been too low
absolutely are we making progress
undoubtedly next time we speak we will
dwell on the pilot a little bit more
dominic rad thank you for being able to
talk to you